hi ray Jack nation Greg Alva here I'm
Luke Cage I'm wearing a Justice League
shirt cuz we're all equal guys we're
gonna watch the trailer second one for
Jessica Jones season two can't wait till
this comes out you best believe John and
I will be covering the episodes at least
the full ones over at our patreon and
some will go up on YouTube you excited
so excited I love the first year and
guys shout out today for none other than
Rosa Parra Rosa
[Music]
my whole family was killed in a car
accident someone did horrific
experiments on me I was abducted raped
and forced to kill someone and I'm in
here
so how is anger management hey still
angry some people call me a hero
[Music]
call me a freak I'm just trying to make
a goddamn living in this goddamn city
Europe I I'm resourceful
people I care about are in danger I
gotta make a decision
one keep denying me far too
do something about it see someone here
[Music]
call me a [ __ ] again just kajal's
a particular short fuse that mess
[Applause]
anything - Miss Jones yeah I always deal
with threats head-on meaning I punch
them in the head until they're
unconscious
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
cool song on the trailer could shows I
actually appreciated how they cut this
trailer because the first trailer for
season 2 was all it was pretty pretty
much like all new footage and this one
so it's a big combination of a lot of
season 1 images of season 2 which I
appreciate because I don't want to see
too much of season 2 and this only
really hints at what I already got from
the season 2 trailer 1 which is we're
gonna see a lot of Jessica's past we're
gonna learn a lot about her past this
time around killer drink a lot of
alcohol out of alcohol no the real new
thing they showed us was that she's
going to anger management which I don't
want her to go to I want her I don't
want to deal every Marvel series needs a
support group yeah now Jessica Jones is
an anger management hey Daredevils next
bud yeah hope so I feel like there's
gonna be a lot in store or that they're
just they don't want to spoil for any of
us right now this is the first trailer
they kind of hint at Trish Walker or
possibly becoming Hellcat she's talking
about - getting Jessica Jones a sidekick
kilgrave does show up and it's been a
couple of new scenes I imagine their
flashbacks or traumatic memories or
something in this trailer you don't
really get much new stuff one thing that
you do see though is she's about to have
relations with a man
yeah while she's painting which is gonna
be a mess maybe when she is painting
maybe it's more than redecorating it's
some new therapeutic treatment she's
doing I imagined this is one of the guys
she met from anger management and if
it's Jessica Jones's look he's a bad guy
or maybe they're both just messed up and
need to have Angry sex yeah just like
Luke Cage and earn some what I'm really
curious where this season's gonna take
us like her past does seem intriguing
and we know I still don't know who the
define villain is of this season it
looks like it has the grit the rawness
Jessica Jones is some people thought she
was the best of the defenders I thought
she was kind of an essential I felt like
she could have been a reoccurring
character on the defenders as opposed to
a series regular here though it means
Jessica Jones's show watching this was
like yeah she was back oh yeah this is
Jessica Jones away for the tone the
style the vibe everything about it well
yeah and it's just such a confident
trailer - and even though there
mixing in a bunch of footage from the
first season I actually like that a lot
too because it makes it feel very
complete and it gives me the idea that
you know we are going to keep that
information fresh in our minds we are
gonna go back it is gonna be kind of
all-encompassing and I'm excited to see
this girl because I really loved the
first season they got to do good with
this one because the last couple haven't
been great but this looks like this
bodes well to me so patron the day
shout-out for men then a Rosa para Lady
Stark of the patron page she loves you
the most
watch a shadow out buddy Rosa I think
you would make a terrific alcoholic a
private eye I think you should leave the
nursing industry medical I stopped
helping people all together learn how to
fight and just go out in the streets get
messed up and punch some people I could
see you being a Jessica Jones type of
badass warrior because you are a family
woman and I know if anyone mess with
your kids you would murder them in a
heartbeat I was gonna say I feel like
roses more of a Frank Castle type Milan
you know like machine guns skull yeah we
gotta test this out Rosa John's gonna
kidnap your kids yeah uh-huh yeah yeah
the best way to experiment is in real
life where the stakes are highest you
know and I like to see what happens when
people are pushed to their limit you
have 48 hours you're at work right now
while this is imperative so haha we're
picking them up after school is it that
improv training you can't find a pathway
out of it you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
really get notified every time one of
our vids is up and check out our patreon
become a patreon ejected a full-length
TV show reactions and music videos over
there as well as weekly Q&A is a bunch
of good stuff